[Musique]
bonjour bonjour dhimmi bonjour à toutes
et à tous bonjour à aden le doubs qui
réalise cette émission et nous recevons
ce matin arlette pigeard bonjour bonjour
vous êtes directrice régionale de
l'antenne martiniquaise du cnfpt un la
délégation de martinique du centre
national de la fonction publique
territoriale
on va dire quelques mots sur cet
organisme mais on va préciser quand même
que vous êtes titulaire entre autres un
d'un dss de gestion et évaluation des
collectivités territoriales obtenu alex
université des antilles et de la guyane
vous êtes également arlette pigeard
docteur en sciences juridiques donc
directrice régionale de l'antenne de
martinique du cnfpt établissements
publics paritaire un donc qui paritaire
ça veut dire que ça regroupe des
incendies personnel et voilà et des élus
donc s'est déconcentré il y en a dans
chaque région de france et c'est un
établissement public et accompagne les
collectivités territoriales et surtout
leurs agents dans leur mission de
service public
alors on parle là des agents qui
travaillent en mairie dans les
communautés d'agglomération cc puis à la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
en tout cas principalement voilà alors
ce matin vous êtes veut nous parle
essentiellement de formation continue
pour les personnels les agents
territoriaux en particulier dans le
domaine culturel
vous avez réalisé des actions en ce sens
notamment récemment une chanson composée
par anthony angèle et vous même et qui
est interprété par le chanteur mc janik
nous y reviendrons mais avant arlette
pigeard vous même en tant que directrice
régionale de du cnfpt martinique et tous
vos agents comment expérimenté vous la
situation de crise sanitaire qui nous
touche depuis quelques mois et dans
laquelle nombre de ses agents
territoriaux sont sur le premier front
en tout à fait nous avons commencé à
travailler sur la rentrée dès la mi mars
des le confinement en fait nous avons
mis en place des webinaires ne pouvant
faire de formation en présentiel avons
mis en place le nombre de webinaires
s'adressant aux agents territoriaux et
je précise qu'ils pouvaient capter
webinaire soit un téléphone portable
elle n'était pas dotée d'ordinateurs
alors pour la rentrée scolaire
bien évidemment dans mis l'accent sur la
pandémie de façon arras
tirée à la fois les agents mais
également les parents les enfants et la
communauté éducative
pas plus tard que la semaine dernière
bien avant la rentrée officielle
nous avons engagé des actions de
formation très forte avec la ville de
fort de france
à titre d'exemple pour 150 atsem agent
technique spécialisé des écoles
maternelles
pourquoi pour rappeler sa rappelle nous
avons fait des gestes barrières l'aîné
videmment distanciation et aussi la
gestion des émotions et la gestion du
stress parce que pour accompagner un
enfant il faut soi-même être libéré de
ses émotions et de son stress pour
vraiment rassurer l'enfant rassurer les
parents et prendre en charge cet enfant
là pendant sa scolarité et nous avons
également eu l'idée d'aller dans les
écoles rencontrer ces agents qui
nettoyait justement désinfecter les
écoles prendre un peu le pouls et leur
demander quelles étaient leurs
sentiments qu'elle est énorme et théo
comme on dit par rapport à la rentrée
scolaire et nous avons eu des agents
très engagé très investis qui nous ont
rappelé que pendant la pandémie
ils ont déjà travaillé puisqu'ils ont eu
à accompagner les enfants du personnel
médical
donc globalement ils font face il faut
facéties des fonctionnels voilà et je
les salue
je sais que sont des femmes en règle
générale je les salue par
professionnalisme et nous avons
accompagné dans ce sens alors justement
parmi donc les fonctionnaires
territoriaux
il y a effectivement des agents qui sont
cadres qui sont diplômés qui ont suivi
des études et puis il y en a qui n'ont
pas ce niveau d'études
la chasse qui n'ont pas eu la joie la
mémé unique dont le travail est sans
doute aussi utile tout aussi utile tout
à fait alors en tout c'est à peu près
dix huit mille agents de la fonction
publique territoriale qu'il y a en
martinique
justement on le disait dont une large
majorité issus de la catégorie c'est
donc ils ne sont pas des cadres moyens
ou cadres supérieurs et dites-vous qui
sont souvent aussi éloignée de la
formation en certains soient éloignés de
la formation simplement parce qu'ils ont
en mémoire les traumatismes subis à
l'école souvent ou alors ils n'ont pas
confiance en eux et pensent qu'ils sont
trop âgés trouve éloigné de
l'enseignement de l'apprentissage
ils se disent
ottawa c'est au travail simplement sans
développer ses compétences on nous
sommes là pour leur dire justement que
nous existons que nous sommes là nous
sommes à leurs côtés et nous sommes
sensibles à l'évolution de leurs
compétences à l'évolution de leur
carrière aussi et nous mettons en place
des actions pour eux de façon à ce
qu'ils puissent sa culture et au
numérique puisque aujourd'hui rien ne se
fait sans le numérique et il faut pas
qu'il soit déconnecté de ce numérique
est une méthode par exemple des
formations en place pour aller à la
rencontre d'un ordinateur tout
simplement apprendre à utiliser
l'ordinateur et apprendre à être à
l'aise dans les actes quotidiens de la
vie alors donc votre souci c'est de
garantir l'égalité d'accès à l'offre de
formation pour l'ensemble des agents
vous avez signalé le domaine du
numérique mais vous faites aussi de la
formation dans le domaine culturel
et pour ça vous avait même signé une
convention avec l'adac la direction des
affaires culturelles en martinique
oui c'est tout nouveau donc depuis
l'année dernière ont signé cette
convention au pourquoi simplement parce
que pour nous était fondamental que nous
puissions accompagner les collectivités
dans leurs politiques culturelles et
nous sommes aperçus qu'il y avait de
nombreux agents qui n'avait pas de
formation dans ce domaine qui étaient
affectés aux bibliothèques aux
médiathèques et dans les services
culturels des communes et nous avons
tenté les accompagner alors ça cela se
fait par plusieurs paliers bien
évidemment nous commençons à commencer
l'année dernière par les bibliothèques
médiathèques et nous allons continuer
avec une formation d'auxiliaire de
bibliothèque qui est extrêmement une
formation extrêmement important d'être
certifiés qui permettra de former un
certain nombre d'agents et puis nous
allons poursuivre au niveau des musées
vous savez qu'il y a pas plus tard
qu'hier soir il ya eu un reportage sur
l'archéologie
bien évidemment nous allons former aussi
ses agents la à l'archéologie également
une services techniques ce qui a des
fouilles également donc il ya un gros
travail va se faire au niveau des musées
au niveau de l'accueil des publics au
niveau également nous avons une
population qui vieillit
comment recevoir des personnes d'un
certain âge un aux musées bibliothèques
et médiathèques du matiko soda politique
culturelle avec pigeard directrice
régionale du cnfpt martinique et votre
équipe vous dites que vous avez aussi
une attente forte que les élus
je vous cite quand même élabore une
véritable politique culturelle qu'elle
soit les ide se disant qu'elles soient
lisibles plus lisible pourquoi parce que
nous formons évidemment des agents dans
le champ de la culture des politiques
culturelles
ces agents ont des missions et il faut
qu'ils aient les moyens de remplir leur
mission
donc ce sera effectivement les décideurs
qui délègue les finances pour cela et il
est important aussi que l'élu soit
sensible à l'évolution des politiques
culturelles et les accompagnent alors
vous avez réalisé déjà un certain nombre
d'actions justement dans ce domaine de
la formation à la culture et finalement
à l'expression culturelle inde en
dansant dans sa vie professionnelle
finalement pour ces agents donc vous
avez fait une exposition collective
d'art par exemple territoriale emprunt
territoriale donc d'arts plastiques
incessants inciter les agents à révéler
leurs talents de nombreux agents des
talents peinture en sculpture en photo
et ça reste confidentiel
ils le font j'ai envie de dire chez eux
dans une pièce là on a permis de révéler
au grand public leurs talents
voilà vous avez également réalisé
effectué un séminaire sur la musique sur
les femmes noires dans notre histoire
et puis là tout récemment la création
d'une chanson donc composé entre autre
part vous avec anthony angèle qui a été
tourné en vidéo clip alors bon
malheureusement on voulait vous mettre
quelques extraits mais bon techniquement
on n'a pas pu mais voilà alors une
chanson tourné en vidéo clip qui met en
valeur les métiers territoriaux
la formation et la fonction publique
territoriale dit nous en quelques mots
nous avons voulu simplement dit à tous
les agents que nous sommes là et nous
sommes à leurs côtés
à leurs côtés c'est à dire que un agent
l'idée est venue simplement parce que
nous voulions développer une campagne de
communication et au lieu de faire une
campagne classique on a eu l'idée de
mettre en chanson le message tout
simplement en disant aux agents venez
nous rejoindre au cnfpt
venez développer vos compétences venez
aussi être au contact de la population
chanson message message pourra tout à
fait faire adhérer pour interpeller et
faiblesses et ses agents ses achats et
ça marche je me doutais que sa mort
j'espère
on aura une autre occasion la chance de
pouvoir écouter quelques mesures de
cette chanson alors mc janik c'est
plutôt un toaster quoi il fait plutôt sa
main justement cette fois sur ce mode là
oui tout à fait et m6 janica a su mettre
en valeur cette chanson le message il a
compris tout à fait le messager je le
salue je sais qu'il est l écoute et ça
marche parce que ça si sonné ça fait le
buzz en martinique la bombe encore
comment comment peut- être que jimmy on
lui proposera peut-être un de ces matins
ils désirent passera la chanson composée
par du jard interprété par mc janik on
va faire ça on va faire la connexion
avec avec jimmy dites moi qu'est ce que
c'est quoi le message exactement d'une
butte nous une ou deux fois par an pâle
cnfpt kaba rampal on s'incline dès qu'il
ya du créole de danse et bien voilà le
crime est sous-titré puisque nous avons
des collègues dans les délégations du
cnfpt qui ne sont pas à créer le fonds
est bien évidemment pour que tout le
monde puisse avoir accès et je peux vous
dire simplement que ces deux mots 4
parole bah tout tout la mairie la ctm
épi d'autres collectivités
je ne vais pas me laisser chanter il
peut déjà si j'avais commencé voilà
voilà
il nous reste un peu plus d'une minute à
peine arlette pigeard donc on le
rappelle vous êtes ici en tant que
directrice régionale du cnfpt de
martinique pour nous parler des actions
de formation que vous faites à
l'intention des des agents notamment
dans le monde culturel mais mais vous
avez d'autres corde à votre arc et vous
êtes écrivaine aussi vous avez déjà
publiés on le sait vous êtes voilà et
puis vous venez d'être fait chevalier
c'est ça ce valley où je vais lire
chevallier je crois plutôt qu'on dit de
l'ordre des arts et des lettres
ça date de juin dernier la juin dernier
donc on le signale en passant on va
terminer parce que vous avez en projet
un ouvrage sur le lycée schoelcher
d'avant d'avant 2020-2021 celui qui est
en train d'être achevés la carence
chantier et vous fait un appel à des
témoignages pour ça alors je tente de
recueillir les témoignages d'anciens
élèves lycée seule chair mais également
d'anciens professeurs d'anciens
surveillants du personnel administratif
pourquoi pas ce que je veux faire
revivre revivre ce lycée depuis son
origine
1937 à la fermeture du lycée des
témoignages riches qui vont permettre à
tout un chacun de connaître
j'ai envie de dire ce qui se passait au
coeur des lycées en dialyse est d'accord
et on rappelle que dans le veau et
ouvrages précédents vous avez fait
beaucoup en oeuvre de justement de
transmission d'une fratrie sites de
patrimoine du patrimoine 1 notamment sur
les anciennes boutiques là les autres
épiceries
voilà merci alain pigeard d'avoir rien
votre invité en ce vendredi matin
et puis bonne chance pour la suite de
vos actions au cnfpt juste dire que ça
fait dix ans que je suis au sénat fêter
ce mois ci bon ben voila je libère sa
merci